champion tu connais les sleecs honda je
refuse de lui faire signe un contrat
avec barcelone et d'élus on voit demain
champions au botswana dans mon pays
d'origine
il va être décoré par le président de la
république du botswana dimanche matin
avec ma [ __ ]
bienvenue au pays mon fils le portugal a
demandé monsieur le président autant
vous dire que nous sommes honorés de
répit
didier l'agent
homosexuel mais je suis contre
l'adoption 1 8l boro et sa femme
jacqueline vous le merci de votre
présence
mais si mes enfants depuis l'algérie
je suis rarement senti aussi bien depuis
quand ne donne que doit être la kate
middleton plus ronde est super regarder
avec des pros france la pomme
l'hippopotame quelle vidéo le tout net
je les fais rr les citations leslie
kanda guadeloupe pour les composites du
botswana où un million quatre ans on la
connaît logique de l'équipe de france
quand vous gagnez cela prend black blanc
beur qui triomphe puis dès que vous
perdez c'est ça suffit a trop
d'étrangers dans l'équipe
monsieur le président si vous les pièces
qui joue pour le bo de son gagne faut
absolument leur vie au village de sa
mère à bord il aurait balancé ses
cendres la [ __ ] parle du vent a pas de
ta mère je vais vous présenter mes
enfants tant marie marine mario goethe
en famille à la peau malines emma les pv
donné quoi bouffer c'est du bon
c'est de l'opposant politique
j'attends demain comme d'une n'a pas de
roi revient la girafe qui semblait pas
possible on est où là
onana flec colonisateur
ça c'est la maline à son bobo est tué
pour guinée café à lemon conquis